well yes i think that i don't think it's
sort of
ethereal exactly or at least it depends
what you mean by ethereal but i think
it's a field
i think these things work through what i
call morphic fields yes
and morphic fields are fields and
um in science we have quite a number of
fields
and there's the magnetic field around
the magnetics you can't see the magnetic
field
it's in the magnet and it's around it
the gravitational field around the earth
it's an invisible organizing structure
that keeps the moon in its orbit and
keeps us
down on the ground then there's the
electromagnetic field of your cell phone
which is
active inside the cell phone but extends
invisibly beyond it
and now all of these are fields and the
point fields were first introduced into
science in the 1840s
they're not part of the original
newtonian mechanistic picture
and most of our modern technologies are
field-based technologies i mean
right now we're talking on zoom the
whole of this works on electromagnetic
fields and transmissions and so on
so i think morphogenetic fields probably
the form shaping fields and morphic
fields which is the generic term to
cover
form shaping fields and behavioral
fields and social fields
um i think these are actual organizing
fields invisible
organizing structures their patterns or
regions of activity
in space and time and so it may sound
the fact they're invisible and they
organize things invisibly
some people would say oh wow this must
be pseudo sciences woo
and so on but actually that's the basis
of the whole of modern science the whole
of modern science is explaining the
visible in terms of the invisible
and once you get into quantum matter
fields
and uh the quant zero point energy field
and the higgs boson field
uh we're dealing with a whole range of
fields which
underlie reality they're invisible they
give structure and order and formed
things morphic fields is another kind of
field we've already got several kinds
within science
but i don't think it's yet an exhaustive
list
yeah you give these those are very
important
examples in the not only
earth's magnetic field the gravitational
pulls
the all the technology in the last 150
years is
now functioning off of these invisible
fields to to the human eye this is very
important but also
even further more when you look at even
just something as simple as a tree
the tree is not just a static tree
there's a massive field around the tree
that is constantly doing the
the o2 and co2 exchange that is it's
just
happening all over with from the leaf
sections all the time
and if you're next to it you're inhaling
that and exhaling so
you're like you're there's so that's
also a big funny thing with the whole
identity thing if you identify yourself
as just your ego
or if you identify yourself as also that
tree
that's a little bit of a separate thing
but you you give
also this really important point about
uh social groups i think is
very important like you just listed
there's just there's something
else happening so we're gonna co-exist
these concepts of genetics epigenetics
and the way science is understanding the
collective
inheritances of of memory but we're also
going to
add to that picture we're going to add
to that
something else that is that that's
occurring across
a morphic field for humans and there's
got to be ways to do this better i mean
we'll give this brief example in sports
and then i'll i'll make the
the the question here but just
it's so true that in social groups
there's almost some sort of a a morphic
field that happens if you've ever been
around
especially in like northern california
what happens is you have
an extremely um
homogenized perspective about a specific
topic
and you basically can't you can't really
enter a new idea
into like a social group if there have a
homogenized idea
and with athletes there's something
going on with
athletes and myself and one have played
for so long different sports
especially in team sports where there's
some sort of a
collective intelligence that's happening
that is it's
it's in a sense it's it's some sort of
an extra sensory perception
and there's something going on between
the teammates where they're able to be
in complete
surrendered flow to communication
and sharing so ultimately rupert what we
can have science do to further prove
this
is more randomized controlled trials
around
how our capacity to quickly
learn around the world new ideas
and so this can be a way for science to
further probe and understand that
with all these examples
um yes well looking at social fields
um yes i think that there are fields
that organize social groups and i've
looked at these in
animals because all social animals have
social fields they all have to
coordinate members of the group
and when you look at flocks of starlings
for example which we have here in
england in the winter
huge flocks of up to a million birds
they fly around before dusk
and the whole flock can change direction
almost immediately without the
individuals bumping into each other
they know not only where the others are
but where they're going to go
and the same is true of schools of fish
and so there's something about animal
groups that
they can be coordinated by some kind of
invisible connection
and the best computer models of these
flock behaviors
treat them as as fields as if they're a
bit like iron filings in a magnetic
field
each individual iron filing is not doing
the organizing itself it's within a
larger structure
of which it's part and i think members
of social groups
are like that i think that's why
you were talking about a kind of
consensus views that you get in
societies i mean
scientific paradigms are like that
thomas kuhn pointed out
that with at any given time scientists
share a common model of reality a
paradigm
um and anything that doesn't fit in is
dismissed or ignored
or treated as heretical but then there's
a scientific revolution
and another paradigm takes out over
another model of reality
um and then the same thing happens again
i mean
his model of scientific revolutions was
rather like
sort of old-style latin american
military
dictatorships where you have a kind of
dictatorship that's replaced by a
different dictatorship
it wasn't scientific revolutions have
involved replacing one dictatorship of
ideas with another they haven't
none of them's yet been like the
declaration of independence
where the sort of democracy hit science
uh we're still in the old model of um
you
know
at any given time and right now the
dominant world view is mechanistic
materialism
it's coming apart at the edges and it's
as i show in my book sunset free called
the science delusion in the uk
um these dogmas of uh materialism
are actually being outgrown by science
itself we're going beyond them
so there's there's a sense in which
social fields can strain
our thoughts they also link us together
and in team sports
um they can lead to this coordination
that's
sort of unconscious and almost
automotive sort of automatic and
michael murphy looked into this you know
the founder of the
esslin institute who's very keen on
looking at sports as an evolutionary
phenomenon
and in his book the psychic side of
sports um
co-authored with rio white he um
talks about how interviewing he
interviewed american football players
and a lot of them felt they were sort of
telepathic with other members of the
team
but none of them dared say so in the
locker room because they thought the
others would think they were weird
um but this is going on all the time i
think
in in sports activities and
it's this connection between members of
groups within the social field that
underlies
telepathic phenomena like dogs knowing
when their owners are coming home
and mothers knowing when their baby
needs them when they're miles away from
the baby
so i think we're linked together with
members of our families and members with
other social groups through these social
fields
ultimately this is our responsibility
to create randomized control trials to
probe
this